let's bring in the former NBA former
North Carolina player he's got think
three NBA championship rings he's Rick
Fox joining us on the program
you got three championship rings Rick
2002 when do you wear them I used to
wear them at this time of year if I
attended the NBA Finals for NBA TV when
I when I worked with with NBA TV I'll
wear them occasionally if I go to an
event where I'm speaking because I know
individuals will want to see it the
stories the stories are great but they
want to touch and feel the actual
hardware if I said you can only get one
ring out of the house yes which ring and
one's 2001 because the the 2001 run was
the 15 and one stretch where we blew
through the first three rounds of the
playoffs and we were as in sync as I
think I've ever been with teammates and
a coaching staff on the floor and we
almost were perfect in the NBA run-up to
that championship that year but it was
there was a level of confidence that we
stepped on the floor with which was
intoxicating and it is something I never
felt again what about that one launch
yeah that was the six or loss were
bananas we lay off we were slightly uh
maybe a sluggish Kobe didn't have his
best game Shaq didn't have his best game
and yet we still went into overtime
that's the game you see a lot of the
highlights with I was just stepping over
to wrong Lou but it was the one that got
and they deserved it that night and to
this day I think we could have maybe
gone down as the greatest team ever if
we got on defeated give me a Kobe story
I haven't heard before
well you've probably heard a ton of them
I've ever told you the one after the
preseason game where he stepped onto the
bus and I think he'd scored 28 points in
the fourth quarter yeah he didn't play
in the first half and he was Dell Dell
Dell Harriston to play him the first
half of the preseason game and he scored
28 points in the fourth quarter but he
stepped on the bus and he said to me
said Rick I think I could have scored 73
points tonight 73 points how'd you do
that sure enough you know eight years
later I'm a sitting courtside of a Laker
game I'm retired and it's a year out and
they're gonna honor me at the game and
he scores 60 points in three quarters if
somebody's gonna score 100 in a game
again like will did who would be that
one person his staff got on a streak and
knocks down 23 and just in a you know a
fit of he checks and then you know at
some point team gets so frustrated they
just start fouling them to try and stop
them and then the perfect free-throw
shooter so it goes the other 30 or 35
points yeah how would your best Laker
team do against this Golden State
warrior team I don't know who's playing
tonight ok ok let's say they're all
healthy Rick they're all healthy and you
pick your 2001 Laker team right can you
step back as an analyst and be honest in
assessing who would and I know it's
different eras different you know
different officiating different rules of
what you get away with and all that but
let's say the 2001 Lakers were playing
today's NBA rules against a fully
assembled Warriors team yes now we've
done this exercise for myself because
I'm so impressed with this current
Warriors team and I'm also finally
enjoying the current style of play of
the NBA it's entertaining but it's also
really really fast and and skill sets
are increasingly better quite frankly
than I think
even our error when it comes to the
range of shooting the speed with which
they you know they conduct offensive
execution and a full court set so I'm
gonna give them that credit to begin
with style of play is going to be huge
if physicality is allowed they do not
beat us if we can't touch them
physically defensively it'd be hard for
our error to keep up with them at this
pace because they're so fast they're so
free flowing but I tell you defensively
the game would be decided because they'd
have to send half of their team to do
anything with Shaq in the paint I mean
they wouldn't just have to literally
send three guys to do anything they're
probably the core their front line would
file out in the first half if they did
decide to double-team him we had
shooters they are Trish Suhr Robert
Horry myself you know which we're all
shooters so we rarely got open shots
when we did we loved that because we
knocked them down look at the matchups
Derek Fisher on a physicality level
would have been aggressively in Steph
Curry he'd be able to chase him he'd be
able to put a body on him physically
which which I think would wear wear
staff down
Kobe Bryant all defensive player would
would be able to you know guard anywhere
from the you know two to four internt
depending who's playing that in terms of
a size matchup if you're looking at it
and you're saying they're going small
and three Mazda for 5mins Rick who wins
the series in our era and we'd have to
get away with beating them up in their
era right now today but I definitely
think that people forget how athletic
Shaq was and they think will shock
wouldn't be able to keep up with these
guys I disagree Shaq ran the floor
faster than anyone just as fast as
anyone on our team and I think we we
would take that series your favorite
Shaq story is what we all had to decide
whether or not we were going to practice
with him butt naked because he he loved
to do that and he loves he loves to like
hug people and he's naked like right and
what are you doing are you doing a movie
on the Showtime Lakers or isn't it is in
a documentary so it's a TV series with
Adam McKay Max Borenstein Jim had a
great great director oscar-winning
director and showrunners from television
we do a series just recapping the 1980s
Showtime era and it's a book from Jeff
Perlman yeah yeah yeah celebrating the
icon from that era I know you're doing
stuff with eSports and I'm fascinated
with this in fact the campus of Full
Sail University they have an eight and
eSports program there that you know kids
come from all over to actually learn how
to do eSports you have a podcast here
what what what kind of captured your
imagination with eSports video games
something that I've done with my kids
something I've done my friends
throughout my life I cut my teeth
personally competitively on an Atari
2600 back in the mall I found the
basketball so I was there on my five my
competitive fire was ignited the pilot
light came on there eSports for me just
I experienced it live and and I did in
Madison Square Garden back in 2015 and
it was in that moment that I saw arenas
being filled I saw a generation that
obviously technology has afforded them
the pleasure of playing games on their
phone playing on their laptops
entertaining himself maybe differently
than we did as kids we came from the era
of put down the video game controller
and get out of the house and in this
generation if you tell them that they'll
put it down pick up the phone and
they'll play games on their phone so
they want to express themselves and and
some of the best of the best just like
in any field have risen to a level where
they're entertaining to watch the things
they do are unique and it's not easy to
be done they they're the best in the
world and now they're getting paid for
it
they're sponsored to do it there's
leagues and franchises and I just happen
to fall in love with one of the games
League of Legends and I have an eSports
organization that could Pete's in that
game we have some of the best players in
the world and so I I'm in that culture
now for the last five years and I
thought we'd do a podcast the GG podcast
to celebrate games to celebrate eSports
to talk about things that are happening
culturally around videogames
he's Rick Fox three-time NBA champ the
podcast the GG podcast the gaming and
eSports podcast available on podcast
one.com Apple podcast and the podcast
one app we keep trying to get Ray Allen
to do a sequel to he got game yeah
Denzel says he's up for it rich says
he's up for it and I as Denzel and he
said I'm fine he said you know get Spike
and you know get something going but I'm
wondering what would the sequel be to he
got game I mean it's been over 20 years
I think you have to it's generational
right you need to have to you know you
know Jesus Shuttlesworth is now himself
a father baby is now maybe it's not a
son maybe it's a daughter III think you
college basketball today maybe his son
is figuring out whether to go straight
to the pros I think the storylines spike
is obviously Oscar nominated writer and
director so he can he can figure it out
I think it's just probably scheduling
and timing and and I love I love the
idea of revisiting where that character
Jesus Shuttlesworth as iconic as he was
along with his you know spike as his who
would be a grandfather
that's like Denzel would be probably a
grandfather cuz he had two fellows works
son getting involved again and his son's
life and what do you remember about
shooting that oh I had two memories and
I still have
some improved from those memories too I
remember the two scenes that will I
remember the first time I'm auditioning
for it I walked in that casting
directors office in New York would spike
and and out came a Milla Jovovich she
just auditioned for the character role
of the prostitute and in behind me
walked an 18 year old rosario dawson no
blush
she signed then she just got off of the
show kids achieved that movie kids that
she'd done mmm-ah she asked me to borrow
my headphones I mentor my head phones do
you wanted to get prepared for her scene
and I went and it was Ray Allen and
Travis best of myself auditioning for
these characters and in the casting
office was just spike and I think Tyler
the casting director and we get done
with the scene and we hear this this
clapping and it's neither of them
clapping and we're wondering he was
clapping and in the closet on the floor
was sitting down to Washington thing I
remember about that movie was being on
set and shooting probably one of the
most eye-opening scenes for me as chick
Deegan recruiting Jesus Shuttlesworth to
come to tech you
and as they recruited on campus and I've
done this before not to this level but
you show the guys you show the high
school kid around you wanted to feel
good about the school and fall in love
you want to introduce them to the young
ladies and in this case through the
women that were playing the assistant
coaches was entertaining Jesus
Shuttlesworth with were two famous porn
stars Polaroid with these two women just
to remember that you know I was on set
with these two women and I had those
Polaroids for the day and uh boy I go oh
man I was 20 years ago and and we did
this scene and the scene became iconic
it became really iconic and because
everywhere I go now people want me to
recruit them to come to college that
didn't happen at North Carolina when you
were recruited no I
I didn't have that type of recruiting
tactics hey good luck with a few things
here with Showtime and also certainly
with the GG podcast great to talk to you
again and we appreciate your time as
always Rick I'm saying Toronto I just I
just think home court advantage I don't
know the health even if Durant and/or
clay play tonight I just don't know how
healthy they're going to be and I don't
know I just get a weird feeling that
we've we've forgotten about Toronto the
entire playoffs and here they are and
then you kind of look up and you go oh
my gosh you know what they're pretty
good team the health of it all is gonna
make is gonna be the difference maker in
this when we won three games but we
weren't three championships in a row
when you play into June like the
Warriors have done now I think for the
fifth straight year good taxed a tough
physically time that the body we're
seeing happen what actually happened to
our team in our fourth run to a
championship which we didn't make I
popped a tendon in my foot Kobe was hurt
Robert Horry got hurt
Shaq got her you fall apart and they
physically quite frankly are all kind of
you know the wares of playing to June
for five years in a row is catching up
with them if you had your life on the
line and you could have Horry take the
shot or Kobe take the shot putting
parameters around it does he have to
create a shot himself no no no he
doesn't have to create a shot because
that would be easy to be like you would
take Kobe there so yeah they spot up
three that's game your life is it it
hangs in the balance
Robert Horry Oreo or Kobayashi okay all
right you're gonna hear from Kobe
[Laughter]
definitely that hey Rick thank you good
luck and always great to catch up with
you for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app